doch noch vor weihnachten kantone
[Musik]
wo im herbst wenn ich alle fortbildungen
und seit oktober seien die schon erfolgt
berichtet ein ist es zeit zum lesen
eines fordert business ob das in vier
geschichten rund um münchen wo sich als
abend ihr nachfolgt
eine von ihnen ist der hausarzt martin
sieg
hätte ich ein ganz wichtiger bestandteil
und ja einfach machen sie ohne duncan
und m12 konsequenzen überlegen rassismus
dass das mein geschäft zu sehen halte
ich finde sehr schön
mit welcher futter hin
ja ja ja der martin sich regelmäßig mit
freunden auf der jagd in tirol unterwegs
vor gut zwei jahren forschten des
bernard ihn entworfen und sident
schafften nur vier tage die woche und
sorgt für den ausgleich die aktive
martin situation wo es lang begleitet
[Applaus]
weidmann ist perfekt hintergrund ist die
akte sprach sonst natürlich sehr eigen
ist und dass das eigentlich zum lager
gehört und wie intakt die fast schon zu
akquirierte gesagt und dann ist das für
mich eigentlich ist natürlich stoff der
welt sicher mir ganz verstehe das lied
könnt jagd nicht verstehen und das auch
bis zur wissens fremden zu bergen musste
sich die arminia tisch widerstehen
konnte gemacht
es ist die chance schiesst aber daneben
kauft man sich ja sehr gute chance über
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die blumen
all in war christine fahrerin fuhr
ostermundiger sie erstellt hütet sie
ihre erste gottesdienst
[Musik]
ich willigte vielleicht musik hat man
sie auf staus einstellen wie ska st
[Musik]
ja
im ersten block das wünscht
[Musik]
27 jahre lang die der gemeinde fahrer
richten gewirkt
rowling ist bewusst dass sie die nie
besonders kritisch beobachtet wird
[Applaus]
das ist ein trick linzer linie sagt kay
bommer hier britischen ganzes kapitel 12
vers 4 bis 8 und 18 bis 14 grad
immer auch das noch
ihre vorgänger patrick risch frisch
portioniert
[Musik]
der tv hat ihn gefragt warum der tod des
stammpublikums frauen die sagt dieter
frommelt konkrete und blickt die welt
erkennen ob sie wie der punkt nicht als
hippie wahnsinnig spannend wieviel er
kenne er hätte computer card & suites
telefon funktioniert und audi die
applikation von hört ixia klinik
gebracht sie erlaubt ausgang zusammen
gezählt die klare und fröhliche fragen
das hat mir gefallen wie gesagt und rom
habe ich sehr gespannt wie täter sich
bringt im braker hafen im gottesdienst
gestalten
[Musik]
noch drei tage und geselligkeit unter
freunden und am schluss auch pro auf
nachfolger-suche format in siek zusprach
die letzte interessante zeit nehmen alle
ernst nehmen wir bereit das engagement
erstens finanz das wenns nicht unter
vorhalt nehmen die werden auf dem markt
aktiv ist wie fisch auf samstag sonntag
frei aber natürlich dass auch design
liefert praktizieren dazwischen so macht
ganz wichtig wichtig das ist das
oscarpreisträger schon probiert und die
interessant hält sich den verabschiedet
und für das andere projekt in china wo
verständliche wie es nachher schon
erwähnt und jetzt wo sie die nächsten
wochen unser kunde muss ich sie bereit
und interessiert ist
die piste wird sich vor der erste
predigt versende nachfolgerin alina
überraschen
[Musik]
fr
[Applaus]
transportfirmen gekommen ist
liberté vip adam und eva
das stimmt eigentlich bin einsam amtlich
aber wird es danken für sonnenarme
lichtung wenn die heute morgen nicht
aufgestockt
da haben wir euch beruhigen roddick
schafft hier steht sogar im ersten buch
mose traditioneller missverständnis vor
der geschichte person vor langer langer
zeit der herr gott der herr adam gemacht
und hätten eine schöne paradiesgarten
gesetzt
adam alex entrup gott hätte branca mit
ihm und hätte im beruf machen bis wiener
durch die hausfrau wo dann hervor
schöpft und putzt und tablett thema ist
also ganz klasse e und f a und o einer
frau was für eine schreckliche
geschichte
es ist eine von ihnen schönste stunde im
theologiestudium mini professorin für
das alte testament hätte klagt dass das
eigentlich ganz anders versteht mit adam
und eva
hier im tiefen tal im röthenbacher
bilanz einhoven übernahme
milchwirtschaft betrieben hofladen mit
frisch produkt und betreut menschen mit
beeinträchtigung rechten fuß wir das
noch immer sehr sorgfältig mache der
euroleague hamburg endlich endlich
endlich ist das wunderschön grad gut
wenn wir das wieder zurück ja die aktion
nur hat er schließlich machen jawohl
gemeinsam mit dem peter und andreas
richter tom die endlos fertige
sehr gut aus platz für in der stiftung
[Musik]
nach dem super-g super- flasche als gut
die flüge nach diesen anstieg mit
medaillen mit
sicher sie mir realistisch was wassers
wird nichts machen aber dann komme sie
gut vorbereitet auf die suche nach
seiner form hat das land gemacht wie das
geht mit geändert aus und und freuen sie
vortragen dass herr und setzen sie
langsam schon früher hof mit aggro
tourismusbetriebe damals ins turnier
das ist jetzt anders salome und tom sind
besitzer und da muss alles vorwärtsgang
milchbetrieb und dem hoflader wenn sie
hoch zu ross events und spürten beiden
breakfast agierte nur so hat sie auch
finanziell und rechtlich schaffen also
schon einiges gegangen hier stoppen
diese stoffe auch natürlich wie vorher
über noch freie stuhl ist die party noch
relativ langsamen die büros hat über die
ca
da die natürlich priorität ob sie
richtig gesetzt und überall ist 1 85 und
ich muss arbeiten dort ein projekt wie
aus dem büro hat einfach der sache war
wie das der nach haltungs gesetz die
berührende geschichte von adam und eva
unserer neue bibelübersetzung zum
beispiel aber dass der erst mensch in
der biblische geschichte sondern es
geschlechtslos oder modell sieht es
intersexuell was sie da das rund vier
dollar was erde heißt beste übersetzt
erklingen geschäft also dass gott da
kling in einer wunderschönen karte setzt
ins paradies aber detlef gottschling es
ist nicht gut dass der mensch allein ist
und da hat gott adam nimmt die n die
hälfte von dem adam wasser und formt
trust froh und der großangriff wird der
dampfer andere und erwachte aus machen
also sage zählt ist derart links oder
sie froh und man gleichzeitig scharfe
worte aber das natürlich nie so passiert
ist ist glich als wirkmächtige geschäft
für zwei hauses von frau und mann
und wenn man solist ist für mich klar
dass es um beziehungen zwischen mann und
frau geht das andere paar formen wie
zwei frauen mit einem zweimann dass das
irgendwie nicht gut war
es ist nicht gut wenn der mensch alleine
ist
amen
[Musik]
über 30 jahre lang und lieder und reime
auf ihrem hof kurz bevor sie eine bilanz
verkauft hat muss gesundheitlichen
grünen wenn sie der betrieb müsse jetzt
ohne tabus und unterstütze die nachfolge
[Gelächter]
mit mehr
[Musik]
ich habe es einfach für mich und ich
habe und was ich kann
wie muss arzt martin 6 hergiswil hat
sich einiges
nach dreijähriger solchen potenziellen
nachfolger gefunden
die letzte woche etliche kandidaten
vorgestellt und david sind praxisnahe
und seine räumlichkeiten existenz
gemeint hat eine andere vorstellung sie
unterstützt plan das direkte praxis von
martin sechs neue dorfzentrum will park
entsteht eher moderat mit einer
gesundheits zentrum unserer groß praxis
mit mehreren heimischen fit fertig ist
das projekt aber er steht zwei jahre und
das hätte große eifersucht nachfolger
zur zeit von martin sieg da kommt es zu
mehreren praxis zu schaffen müssen wir
noch etwas planen und und ziel ist dass
die sperrte die tür bezüglich und das
wahrscheinlich aus obwohl oder
knackpunkt ist im moment der mord in
syke am anfang auch die idee bleibt die
gemeinde intent unterzeichnet wo
festleiter sie nachfolger sind die
praxis im zentrum will parksaal
weiterführen und gruppenpraxis spur
doch wie sich herausgestellt hat wurden
jemand das unternehmerische risiko gut
finden wir wieder
im krieg meint udo stimmen die gestellt
sich toll in rosa oder hellblau ja
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
westliche musik zu super 2000 mit sehr
geradezu prophetisch zwecke wie sie mit
nachdruck habe mit so tue ich mir schon
noch liaison nachhilfestunden kari
theologische arbeit was die heftigkeit
wenn in der statistik
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die lonza bitte turbulente story
selbständigkeit stunde blindheit
gewertet und bäume im wald quiz knickt
sibitz kubik wald verloren
ufo ihrem betrieb heißt es jetzt
[Musik]
weitere schüsse statt die hand zuerst da
war overhoff verschießen kann den ganzen
kram könnte der schweizer hof bevor sie
darüber nur hand hätte tom immer nun
aber geschafft und sowas grunde kommen
braucht firma firma praktisch von natur
mich sehr denn von natur im sturm ist
machtlos
ja das ist ganz nordtexas möchte nach
romy schneiders das serviceheft aufs
ganze
[Musik]
während der turm der bohrbetrieb betreut
ist salome führer umbau von ruß und für
den aufbau von agro tourismus zuständig
ich glaube jetzt an ihm ein historisches
wissen
das sei aber keine kulisse für den
achtfachen zacher on its erfragen
sondern für sein unternehmen ein starkes
struktur von andreas und peter wo fisch
zur familie gehöre das atom in rumänisch
die hände frei denken lässt und ich
finde schön hätte tachometer kassen
wirklich nicht viel
ein meter raster schottens täglich
wachsen auch gar nicht für mehr freiheit
und weniger feinstaub oder schiff gut
wenn wir arbeiten zusammen machen erst
sammeln oder so 67 aber jetzt bin ich
bei gedauert weil der hersteller noch
geschlagen wird gar nicht so viel
investors and events wie hochzeiten broß
und sonntags brunch erlaubt ihnen quelle
si grund ist der umbau von der terrasse
vor dir deine schaue ich kann dazu noch
[Musik]
wunderbar bis zum mittag um 12 uhr nach
hat dank des appetits er aussagt dass
warschau bdst haben die nach der zwölf
starter gezielt zwei japan und nachher
kann man hier noch die dritte aber nicht
unähnlich dem berliner platz machen
sie findet die entscheidend 70 stadt
wird nach volk vom hausarzt so geregelt
werden
wir sind vertreter von kantonsspital
stans die bucher vom megapark
der gemeindepräsident und tv services
agentur wo mit der nachfolgersuche
beauftragt worden ist es geht nicht um
frank nicht weil ich selbstständig sie
das hängt die er oder auch die erwartet
sich etwas befreien vor dem konzept 67
spielte sich in einer gruppenpraxis wo
sie bisher sind aber wenn ich gross
praxis machen mit 56 ärzte sagen am
schluss bin ich wieder dem genau
gleichen ebene besser dass das ist das
was eigentlich für mich vor deiner lüth
und den experten nicht warum die gar
nicht über wegen gross praxis mit der
vorstellung des 24 realität sind dann
ist das richtig verstanden habe person
der drw bereit war den blog system
fertig stromstoß richtigen klare ziel
dass man erste etappe machte zur
heutigen tag und ich mal persönlich
wetter eigentlich hat einen vorläufigen
stopp hinter nico ist gerührt und sagte
einmal es ist uns nicht sondern ich will
immer nur das ziel eine chance den gott
dann zeitig nimmt er nämlich besonders
wenn sie ähnliche visa zur wichtigsten
ganz nicht dass man überhaupt ändern uns
wichtig ist dass wir praxis sie dem
sänger ein sondern der hausarzt und
wunderlich
ein erster schritt ist box ist
übernahmevertrag mit dem herr w mit dem
sieg so dass das machen vielen dank für
pragmatische lösung vorliegt abend uhr
nach volk sind für martin sieg endlich
in die richtige richtung laufen
[Musik]
und dass sie potenziell nachfolgen
der doktor marcelo walkenhorst für
allgemeine innere medizin und aus
deutschland kennt seine ausbildungen die
zwei jahre als arzt in einer
gruppenpraxis kriens aufgestellt
[Musik]
frau hunziker hallo
wie eine frau ganz egal ob krise wohl
freut mich auch dass es jetzt nochmal
sehen können nicht wie geht es ihnen
gesundheitlich aktuell steht ja ja sie
halten sich ja sehr gut mit ihrem alter
gern über 90 sind sehen 92 ja ja ja ja
super schön und dann auch sie hatten
eine politik ist wie so viele jetzt in
der grippezeit genau sie brauchten ja
sogar antibiotika geld das ist ja eher
nicht so häufig bei viren aber das war
dann doch sie hatten fieber und auswurf
gehabt das war dann doch glaube ich gut
so dass wir das so gemacht haben ja ja
danke abgelaufen sein oder soja er schön
ja ja okay für uns sicher alles gute
sie auch ja dann geschah vielen dank
naja sie aber auch bei uns war immer so
angele marcelo wahlkreis schon länger
mit dem gedanken spielt sich
selbstständig zu machen
ja ich habe von anfang an habe ich mich
natürlich gefragt ja soll ich das
überhaupt machen soll ich das wagen soll
ich das risiko jetzt auf mich nehmen und
was ist wenn es dann nicht gut kommt
aber ja wie man so schön sagt während
ich wagte nicht gewinnt und deswegen
habe ich mir einfach überlegt da ich ich
ich muss einfach mal in das abenteuer
und das risiko ist überschaubar und von
daher denke ich dass ich das richtige
mache ja
clark vorher giswil auf den weg und zum
umgang mit der patientin der schlag war
so gut laufen die praxis mit dem stamm
vor über 50 patienten über große vortrag
wird sie in popp für form einer
beliebten vorgang gibt es ich glaube die
sind tatsächlich recht groß ja also ich
hab jetzt einiges von ihnen gehört von
kollegen er arbeitet ja schon hast du
schon seit jahrzehnten in hergiswil erst
eine richtige instanz und davor habe ich
tatsächlich respekt ja es über 35 jahre
tätig gewesen also ärztlich einen sehr
guten ruf aufgebaut und er hat sich zeit
genommen mit den patienten mit denen zu
sprechen und auch sie über jahre dann
immer wieder qualitativ hochwertig dann
zu behandeln und ich glaube da sind
fußstapfen die groß sind die da auf mich
zukommen die ich in die ich gerne trete
aber ich denke dass wird all das macht
man sein
[Musik]
neben der einige sie zum los launisch
ist es zeit für einen neuanfang westlich
verstehen einfach spezielle händen muss
was sonst nicht gibt bin fahre bitte
pure um den ort es klappt ziehen die
ihre nachfolger gefunden und auto markus
hause der handy-pionier s bahn macht
eigentlich bloß weil ich immer auf der
suche nach einem nachfolger fürs
comeback
das ist ein ex iwf dürfte modetechnisch
wege vater haben
experten sprechen experten weiters prüft
oder hatten interesse kollektiven immer
noch also ist einfach finanziell immer
man nicht nur durch respektiv ist mit
dem preis von 330 franken inklusive
beratung festen kundenstamm und kontakt
spezielle haben rief eine spezielle
kundschaft mit persönlicher beratung der
markuskirche überzeugt dass sie lauten
ermöglichen ist gerade in ried wo alles
immer schnelllebiger und unpersönlicher
wird
vor 24 jahren als comeback-termin hamlet
pionier sie inzwischen schaut der handel
mit massa war im internet und im
großhandel immer stärker wurde mit 26
kilo der jetzt in pension frauen um mit
seiner freundin zu verbringen
markus ist sehr sehr ruhig bleibt eine
schnittstelle kenny spezieller für
andere heim war
[Musik]
und das passiert die nächste folgte
markus macht sich gedanken zu seiner
kundschaft hätte sie lieber hund in ihr
hausarzt
aline behandler mit ihren schülern das
thema flucht und 29 cent ihres erste
hochzeit auf dem hof mit 150
das nächste folgt vorabend nach volk
[Musik]